Jake here with a gamespot news update
following an initial tease last week 343
industries has now provided full details
on the free update coming to halo 5
Guardians later this month arguably the
biggest part of the epic called battle
of shadow and light is the introduction
of big team battle multiplayer mode and
four new maps big team battle is an 8 v8
mode and will become the largest non
warzone mode in Halo 5 the new maps are
deadlock basin guillotine and recurve
all of which are inspired by maps seen
in previous games battle of shadow and
light also includes 48 new Rex there are
also more vehicles skins and
assassinations halo 5s big team playlist
battle arrives sometime next week though
343 industries did not announce a
specific date presumably the new Rex
will also be available at the same time
though this was not confirmed halo 5
will continue to expand in December with
the release of the game sports tools
overall 343 will deliver 15 free maps by
next summer halo 5 launched on october
27th and generated a franchise record of
400 million it was also the most played
game on xbox live during its launch week
for more on halo 5 stay tuned gamespot
you